welcome everyone thank you for joining
us today
at the covet 19 scientific track my name
is sarah warren and i'm the senior
director of translational science at
nanostring
and i'll be your moderator for this
session spatial profiling with the
geomix platform can be highly
informative as it allows
a simultaneous interrogation of the
viral pathogenesis
subsequent disease resolution and immune
response
in this track we will highlight results
from a number of studies that apply
geometric profiling to tissues from
covid patients
and show how dsp complements informs and
guides other profiling modalities
a panel discussion with the presenters
will address outstanding questions for
the covid research community and how
coveted studies can drive technology
advances that will benefit
all research areas the speakers
presenting in this track are
alan borzak and rob schwartz from
cornell
medical school allen's a pathologist
rob's a hepatologist there
also stegostore a research scientist at
the broad institute
gordon jang an assistant professor of
medicine at beth israel deaconess
medical center
and david ting a physician and
researcher at massachusetts general
hospital
following the presentations i'll rejoin
the group and start the roundtable
discussion
a quick note of housekeeping if any
questions arise during the presentations
we encourage you to submit them
via the q a box and we'll respond to
your questions by email
now please join me in welcoming all of
our speakers and i will be handing it
over first
to allen borsa
thank you sarah and thank you for the
opportunity to share
the work that rob and i have done here
at wild cornell
we're going to be talking about covet 19
respiratory distressing
syndrome and using your platform
specifically with the goal of dissecting
the root cause of the severity of this
disease
we'll be going through the following
outline um and we will
uh share uh
in the middle i will transition over to
to rob
i'm going to focus in on the pathologic
features and the banking components
so for us acute respiratory distress
syndrome and pathology goes through
phases
and we see those phases um usually as a
day zero and progression uh through
epithelial cell death
um and eventual healing in the lung
we see those stages and we are fairly
confident about
the resolution of these phases based
upon a time of injury and a progression
over several days where
initially there are features of cell
death and necrosis followed by
inflammation and increasing amount of
regeneration
and eventual fibrosis a typical
covid19 respiratory distress syndrome
case showed all these features
of diffuse alveolar damage what's
interesting and what we found in many
cases was that
in addition to the type 2 cell
hyperplasia of regeneration
uh seen at around five to seven days
after injury
and simultaneously a robust robust
interstitial fibroblastic proliferation
at 10 to 14 days we simultaneously saw
new injuries and those injuries in the
form of hyaline membranes and necrosis
which we would have expected at two to
three days
and so these were side by side and what
we found in looking at a large cohort
this of 68 patients from
while cornell mount sinai and italy
was that while we expected things like
type 2 number side hyperplasia
fibroblasts organizing pneumonia
and squamous metaplasia to increase in
frequency
with days of illness we also found an
unexpected thing
that necrosis also increased by days of
disease
for many folks this meant superimposed
injuries that is
oxygen toxicity or low blood pressure or
perhaps super infection
as a cause but leveraging
immunohistochemistry and in situ
hybridization
what we found was something not exactly
what we expected which is
that these techniques showed viral
immuno and viral rna in areas of those
new injuries
and importantly that there were really
three groups that we were identifying
the first group had acute viral injury
in the first week
and in red are a positive both by immuno
and by in situ
but then we saw a second group in which
there was an acute on sub-acute viral
injury
in which we were still able to detect
virus in the lung and surprisingly this
was still present in three of our cases
at four weeks i want to point out that
our experience now is up to
46 autopsy cases and this is a subset of
them
but that there was a third group in
which virus was no longer detectable in
the lung
but that you can see all these little
symbols next to the numbers
where the patients really had either a
comorbid condition
secondary pneumonias or strokes or other
causes of death so importantly these
patients in group three
that were in a healing phase of lung
injury they died of either
lung disease fibrosis super infection
but we were not able to find virus in
these patients and you can see this
takes us out
to over six weeks of illness as well so
in addition to those epithelial findings
we found thrombosis and in these
patients we found large vessel
thrombosis
as well as small microthrombi and in the
panel
on the lower right immunohistochemistry
for cd61
showing thrombosis in in the capillary
bed
and so what we found was that
in these autopsies that this respiratory
distress syndrome is a heterogeneous
disease that we saw cases for sure in a
large proportion especially within the
first four weeks
of a mixture of direct viral infection
and we also saw the effect of some
systemic reaction in the form of
thrombosis
and so we were starting to divide this
heterogeneity into both
viral versus non-viral injuries in the
epithelial compartment
as well as the effect of vascular injury
in the vascular compartment
to account for these simultaneous events
in both epithelium and vascular bed
i we we had at our
disposal some tissues from these cases
because
in the beginning when the
pandemic really hit new york we were
quite
resource limited but because of good
coordination and great collaboration we
were able to
use the best resource we could for
autopsies
we did not obtain brain tissue we did
not freeze tissue because of safety
concerns
but we did in fact put tissue in trisol
for rna extraction
in urea for protein extractions and also
formlin fixation for tissue sections
and this all occurred really i call it
pop-up banking because
we really did this on the fly and with
great personal effort on the part of
of the collaborators and so
for us a choice of a spatial
transcriptomics platform
ideally would work in paraffin would
tolerate the less optimal fixation times
that we get
at autopsy so rna integrity is not going
to be perfect
and we would want to be able to
interrogate the alveolar the airway and
the vascular compartments
if not separately at least in a way that
we can deconvolute
and that we could also incorporate
analysis of viral message
to see whether it localized these areas
of injury
so with that i'm going to turn it over
to rob to take over to take in the next
part of the presentation
um well alan thank you again uh very
much for that
um for that transition
and for that introduction on kova 19 and
our efforts here
um on this project
now as many of you are aware kova 19 has
many open
questions you know a few of these are
just
illustrated here for example are there
different distinct stages of cova 19
induced lung injury and disease
which i think alan addressed very nicely
earlier that based on histology
there appears to be at least three if
not
more phases that are ongoing during this
disease process
but it is very hard just looking at the
histology here without a deeper analysis
to really know
the characterization of this injury and
to try to understand how this injury
process
differs from other viral
infections such as flu how this differs
from a other ards or acute respiratory
distress
syndrome injury processes to know which
cell types are present
within covid19 lung diseases compared to
normal lung
and injured lung and to know whether or
not the spatial organization of cells
and
their relative gene expression is
altered
in covin-19 relative to these other
disease processes
so as alan um already mentioned there's
a lot of advantages to using
a spatial approach for this
type of analysis and actually i'm just
going to jump ahead here
because the first thing we actually did
is we used encounter
to actually evaluate this material due
to concern
whether or not the tissue quality after
autopsy would be robust enough for
analyzing in this type of fashion
and what we were quite happy to see is
that the encounter system
and method of analysis really did
show that there was maintenance of rna
integrity
and that we can see quite profound
differences
um between basically um
virally infected with covid um
samples and then non-virally infected
samples that came from covet patients
but who we had evidence had that they
had already cleared the infection and
you can see here
that um in relative to patients that
have flu versus cova
that there's a quite a different
differential expression of genes that
are over represented
in patients who had had covid or in
patients who had only had
flu so now with that said
um basically you know our objective was
to see
and characterize the lung tissues that
were collected postmortem from patients
that
had covet-related ards who had
ards through flu who had a non-viral
form
or induced ards and then who
had normal law and so basically um these
samples
were analyzed from at least three
patients
um with uh from each group in these four
indicated conditions so a total of
um 16 total were analyzed
the samples as we mentioned were from
formal and fixed paraffin embedded
blocks
and they all were cut very soon prior to
their
analysis and the profiling that was done
with
nana string was using the cta
atlas with the addition of a covid
spiking spike in
and additional genes that we would feel
would be
over represented in lung tissue
so these samples were sent to nanostring
and
basically we actually then analyzed a
variety of different
rois or regions of interest on these
samples either large airway
or vascular zones or velar zones or
the immune infiltrate zones which the
majority of these were
macrophages and so this kind of gives
you an idea of
at least a normal covered you know
analysis
but from normal tissue what we see and
we did analysis for pan ck
and the different immune cells and you
can see that's represented here and
helped guide
us as we did and analyzed and
picked these different regions of
interest
so basically after that was uh completed
the sites uh went through the nana
string pipeline
the different regions of interest were
essentially illuminated library prep
sequencing and data analysis was done
from these
different areas and
basically you can see here the
the the different
zones and the types of genes that were
represented within these zones
either being from the alveolar the large
airway
vascular or from
the immune component zones and
basically the majority of these zones
contained enough
rna such that we only lost a few
of the rois that were analyzed either to
low reads or uniqueness
now interestingly
when the analysis was done you can see
that the normal and flu samples
actually cluster um well together while
the coveted samples seem to have a lot
more variability
as well as the ards samples and while
initially
this was surprising to us maybe this
sort of makes sense given the
broad heterogeneity and diversity that
might be represented or would be
represented within the ards samples
and in the coveted samples
what we then the analysis was performed
looking at differential gene expression
analysis comparing the covalent 19
samples versus flu
the covalent 19 samples versus the
non-viral samples
and the covalent 19 samples versus the
normal samples
and you can see actually that one of the
most differentially expressed genes
um with cova-19 versus fluid covet 19
versus normal
was this gene nr4a1 and um right now we
are still trying to
you know figure out the role that this
gene may that this gene family may be
playing a role in what this is
signifying
uh to us um there are other a variety of
gene families that were also
over represented and basically
that is uh shown here and you know what
we see here
is is that not unsurprisingly um that
cytosine
cytokine signaling for uh from the
immune system was one of the most
overrepresented um you know gene pathway
family and networks
as well as interleukin signaling um
signaling by interleukins tnf alpha
signaling and others
and that um obviously there are a
variety of different gene pathways that
were also
down uh regulate as well
and these are seem to be more related to
fibrosis and things along these lines
which is not surprising again
given the amount of fibrosis and how
rich
in fibrosis and scar is seen
in these uh covid19 samples
um now this is when we're comparing
covid19
to active flu when we're when we're
comparing cova-19 just to kind of
generic
ards we actually again see this over
representation of interleukin signaling
tnf alpha signaling and cytokine
signaling
which basically tells us that even when
we compare
directly to let's say flu which is a
viral illness
or ards which is caused from a non-viral
etiology that even in these contexts
there is a
significant over-representation of
interleukins and in tnf alpha signaling
even though these other diseases
are either caused in one context from
viral causes
or in the other just representative of
the kind of this overall lung
injury process the other component that
we've seen
in the pathology that's represented here
in this analysis
was you know basically the
over-representation of neutrophils this
has been
reported by many groups it's something
that we've seen
on our histology and it's also something
that we see
represented here as well now i think one
of the amazing
um analysis tools that can be done
here is basically single cell
deconvolution based on the gene
expression
that is performed and it basically
allows an analysis to
essentially determine the abundance and
types of the cells that are present
now i know this is a very busy slide
we're not going to dig deeply
into this but you know just pointing out
that you can actually deconvolute this
and you can see in the in the covid
samples you see
a significant over representation of
basically macrophages and neutrophils
as compared to just generic ards and and
the flu samples
and that's just really denoted here kind
of in this um
you know orange grouping of color you
know if we
basically because we know where the the
rois are obtained in space on
these samples you can actually see and
then map
where these cells are in representation
on those rois within the specific
tissues
themselves and you can see you know the
specific
groupings and um of these
within the specific tissues themselves
for macrophages monocytes neutrophils
fibroblast stcs
and t cells and you know if you really
just focus specifically on the
macrophage
macrophages in space you really see that
they're not present in normals
um you know we see this on nostalgia
that's represented here as well
and it basically is confirms this data
um basically you know what
the last thing that was done was just
using rna scope just to kind of confirm
you know tempers to staining you know
the viral staining things
like this and you know basically we
actually see significant alterations
in this and i'm just showing you here
the data for tempers too
um we really see loss of some of the
other targets as well
you know keep mine this is after and
this is an autopsy two after infection
and this is uh has been confirmed by uh
by stainings as well by us and others
so i think the data is very consistent
but has really led us to have a much
deeper resolution as well as cellular
characterization
this is just showing you some of the
pictures here showing
the expression of of tempers too with
just the low-level expression that we
have within our tissues
um you know basically you know low
in in you know the alveoli in some of
the tissues but high in others
and i think this is just representative
some of the different disease states
or presentations that we see within our
our patient panel
so these are just two different patients
where we see this
similarity from patient 17 to 21
but in the initial sample where we see
low expression
this is similarly shown in flu where we
actually see high
representation of 10 2 through almost
all the samples again showing that
there's more variability
present within the coveted samples so
you know i know i just
kind of ran through this data somewhat
quickly but just
concluding here on the geomets data here
in the covet samples where you know i
think we'll be showing here today is a
very large autopsy cohort
consisting of covet 19 related ards
influenza a different virus related ards
non-viral ards and then
just normal with liver uh normal lung
tissue we use
encounter just to characterize these
tissues um
to make sure that what we're seeing is
you know
for that the tissue itself would be
enough quality
to actually continue with the geomex
analysis
what we found was the tissues overall
were of good
quality and i think this was confirmed
in the downstream gmx analysis where
good data was able to be generated i
mean clustering differential gene
expression analysis shows that samples
in the covalent and rds samples are
heterogeneous
well samples in the normal flu groups
are actually rather homogeneous
and that specific gene and gene networks
were upright and overrepresented in both
these analyses
you know rna scope was used to confirm
some of this data in the show that
tempers 2 was highly expressed in the
large airways in some of the alveolar
zones but was very
quite variable among the covet samples
and that quantitative
single cell deconvolution results showed
that different cell types in the
covalent and area samples are more
variable than those
in the normal fluid groups but with that
said was consistent
with the over-representation of certain
cell groups
as compared to histology that we
performed previously
and then finally i just want to
recognize obviously this has been a team
effort here
i want to credit my collaborator alan
borczyk who really
did enormous efforts to help assemble
and do
these autopsies a variety of people in
my lab
specialty omron jaquin chandar
and then former people in my lab angie
frankel and julian park
my variety of my collaborators
and my funding sources for this
work and with that said um i will pass
this off
to our moderators as we move forward um
in these talks and we'll gladly take
questions
uh at the end of this
seminar
and our next speaker will be dr david
ting from massachusetts general hospital
speaking about temporal spatial
heterogeneity
of the host response to sar's kobe 2
pulmonary infection
thank you dr ting
thank you nana string and sarah for
having me here
i'm very excited to be telling you about
the work that we've been doing at the
massachusetts general hospital i am an
oncologist by training
and uh when this pandemic het we uh we
decided to use
uh our our resources and knowledge to
to try to help understand uh the
stars covey to uh lung infection
and as a clinician you know i could save
uh first and foremost uh being on the
wards
uh taking care of covid19 patients that
this is
a terrible disease uh that we really
uh are working together with uh our
academic as well as corporate
collaborators to really understand uh
better ways of diagnosing and treating
this disease
so you know the project really started
with uh
autopsies that were being analyzed the
massachusetts general hospital
we were processing these carefully as
they were at high risk for for infection
for our staff but we were able to get
our protocols through
to uh evaluate ffpe material as uh has
been highlighted by my other speakers
uh we did 24 autopsies that were stars
cov2 qrtcr confirmed cases from the
nasopharyngeal diagnostic
biops analysis 20 of these were from the
massachusetts general hospital four of
them were from columbia medical center
in new york city
we analyzed a variety of organs we
focused on the lungs with three to five
lobes per case we also analyzed heart
bowel kidney liver fat bone marrow
and skin all the extra pulmonary samples
were negative
on rna-ish and most of them were
negative by rna sequencing which we did
as a parallel
technology there were two cases of bound
that were
low positive by arnie seek but we did
not see this by rna ish
so we don't think that these are active
infections in the bowel
in these cases
as you can see here this is the
acd-rna-ish this is
uh the ish probes directed against the s
gene of the sars kobe 2
virus what you can see the red staining
here prominent
highland membrane staining and the
alveoli
as well as intracellular staining and
some areas that we believe are
pneumocytes
this demonstrated that not only was
there extracellular signal
coming from potentially microaspiration
of
virus from the upper airways but as well
as direct infection of
pneumocytes in in the lungs
what we were able to then do was use a
digital image
analysis using the halo platform to
quantitate uh cases that were either low
virus or high virus
we know that obviously a dichotomization
of these
uh particular cases is just one way of
analyzing this but certainly there's a
spectrum
of of different levels of infection
across
our samples
we then did rna sequencing as an
orthogonal technique as well as qrtcr
using the cdc
approved qrt pcr probes um and in fact
we were able to validate our rna-ish
results and as you can see here um
we see multiple genes of the
virus being expressed and detected by
rna-seq in
certain cases so in case one we have
very high levels case nine we have very
high levels
in other cases like case two and three
we have a
nearly undetectable virus and so again
we see the spectrum of
high virus cases and low virus cases
that indicate that
there are potentially two different
types of infection
but more likely that what we're seeing
is a difference in temporal
development of the disease across
patients
to assess this we we then asked the
question
well if this is true if this is a
temporal difference
is there a difference in time between uh
the duration of disease
uh before autopsy and what you can see
here is that the
low virus samples shown here in blue
that they had a longer duration of
illness before succumbing to the disease
while our um high virus cases typically
were patients that succumb to the
disease from
a rapid decline in pulmonary status
and so what this indicated is that again
as as others have shown is that there's
probably a disease spectrum that
represents
uh the temporal development of disease
and the evolution of the disease in our
patient population
in terms of um then looking at the rna
seq data this is bulk rna seq data we
were
able to cluster based on rna-seq
using most variant genes and what we
found was that
you can see a large number of viral
genes being expressed
as expected in our high virus cases and
there are a lot of gene sets that were
enriched here that were
common in turn including interferon
gamma and alpha singling which was our
number one
signature as well as emt and coagulation
there was this next set that was kind of
mixed of high virus and low virus
samples it's
more of like an intermediate phase or
sort of as the disease is progressing we
believe
we would see indications of wound
healing in
myogenesis so the potential scarring or
fibrosis of the lungs occurring at this
point
finally in low virus cases again this
would be later in the disease phase we
believe that we are seeing
a significant amount of what pneumocyte
regeneration or recovery
with increased expression of surfactants
mucin and keratin genes in this set over
here
so when we focused on the the high cases
what we found was that the interferon
gamma response genes were
highly enriched these are multiple
interference gamma response genes shown
here the
based on gene set enrichment uh using
m6db from the broad
and what you can see is that the
interference signature is much higher in
our high virus cases compared to our low
virus cases
this is a consistent pattern that was um
seen
in our new york samples as well from
colombia
and when we looked at immune cells that
may be
different we use starburst sword to
deconvolute
immune cell populations and what we
found was that we could see
significant amounts of macrophage
signatures
across most of our samples actually from
the high and the low virus samples
but when you use cyberstar you can sort
of differentiate potential m0
through state of macrophages as well as
m1 and what we would see
in our cases is that high virus cases
tended to have high m1 macrophage
infiltrates
which was statistically significant we
confirmed this with immunohistochemistry
just for the macrophages we don't have
great ihc markers for m1 m2 subtypes
but again we see a predominance of cd
163 positive macrophages
in most of our lung samples whether they
were high or low
for the virus
when we focus on the low virus cases in
this analysis
by differential expression we saw
significant amounts of surfactant genes
as you can see over here as well as
mucin genes
you're quite heterogeneous in terms of
which
patients were producing surfactant and
museum genes this could represent
differences in timing this was confirmed
by iac
with napsin a which is a fairly specific
marker for the
uh type two pneumocyte as well as
keratin
which uh showed that these levels were
higher in our
virus low samples and so this would
indicate to us that potentially this is
the time of recovery of some of the
pneumocyte function after
initial destruction by the virus in the
early phase
we then looked at signaling pathways in
particular
jak 2 and stat 1 stat 2 were
significantly higher in our high virus
cases based on rna-seq indicating that
these pathways
may be important for the initial immune
response to the virus
and this does have some implications for
some of the trials
that include jack and converse that are
ongoing in
phase three trials currently in addition
we looked at il-22 pathway there was a
recent study showing that cxcr6
which was a a step finding found in
a large gy study to be uh potentially
affecting uh outcomes in patients and
what we saw that there was significantly
lower amounts of crcr6 at the expression
level on high virus
cases compared to low of course this is
early data and needs to be confirmed but
suggests that there may be some
involvement of il-22 and cfcr-6
pathway activation in uh covid uh
19-infected lungs so all these
initial studies and these are techniques
that we've developed the lab for cancer
research
are are looking at mostly in the setting
of a bulk analysis
and targeted rna analysis and tissues
and so we wanted to expand upon this
and we turned to the nanostring geomets
platform
which is able to look at both proteins
and
rnas on ffpe slides in multiple regions
of interest in using the sars kovi to
viral rna-ish we could use this to guide
our
roi selection for this type of analysis
and here what you're seeing here is a
lump specimen this is the stars cov2
probe against the s
gene and as you can see here we are able
to then overlay
these rna-ish images with the genomics
images and can select areas that are
cited keratin positive or immune cell
positive
um that are positive or negative for the
sars cov2
virus
when we looked at regional variations uh
with
our colleagues at nanastring who
provided all the
infrastructure to do these types of
analytics we saw
an interesting thing uh in that
different immune responses were actually
seen where the virus
was in this first case we see here in
the left upper lobe of case one we see a
predominant
monocyte and macrophage infiltrate where
the sars cov2 virus can be detected
as shown in red while there are some
amount of t and nk cells the prominent
infiltrator appears to be macrophage and
rich
in the same patient in the left lower
low we found a very interesting
enrichment of dendritic cells
plasma cytodendritic cells t cells and
nk cells where the virus is but a very
little monocyte or macrophage
temperatures
this really highlights the intro patient
heterogeneity of the immune response
that is important to um to understand as
a potential
thing that we need to consider in the
setting of clinical trials
the other cases that we saw were more
consistent with this macrophage monocyte
infiltrate with k7 and our other cases
showing this
infiltrate here the very last case over
here
case two is actually a low virus area
and what you can see is there's high
macrophage
infiltrate areas here with the active
virus indicating potentially this is
post-resolution of viral clearance but
residual macrophage infiltrates in
in our samples unsupervised clustering
of these regions of interest now so this
is across all the patients and not
looking at
one single patient we saw a very clear
clustering of two different clusters
the sars cov2 positive cluster cluster
one were enriched over here while the
negative controls that we have
that work from source code between
negative autopsies as well as sarco v2
negative rois we're enriched in cluster
two doing differential expression
between cluster one and two
we see multiple genes shown in this
volcano plug
on the red side we see ccl15
ssx1 were significantly higher and
almost out louder
outliers in our sars kobe 2 high
specimens
when we then looked at those genes we
again saw
interferon gene expression highly
enriched in our high virus
cluster cluster one and when you do
unsupervised
when you do supervised clustering using
the interferon genes you can sort of see
very clearly here that the cove copin 19
or stars cov2 rna
ish positive areas are overlaying where
the interferon responses
and so this uh really told us that there
was a lot of
focal response the interference response
was very focal to where the virus is and
this has been an
area that people have been debating of
whether or not you can
actually generate a a large response
to the virus or if patients actually
have defective interfering responses
when we actually looked at the
interferon gene signatures we saw
something that was very interesting at
the spatial level
and what you can see here is that uh the
esteem or orf1
genes of the virus in these high viral
cases in case
one uh you can see that there's a
significant amount of certain interferon
response genes like
cxcl10 cxcl9 and ido1
and we're very focal to where the virus
was
interesting interestingly the mhc genes
and interferon response genes like ifit3
were more diffuse in the lungs although
higher in patients with sars cov2 virus
did not seem to be much higher in the
areas where the virus is
in the lungs it became that the viral
response to
with interferon response genes is very
focal and the types of genes from the
interferon response are also focal in
those areas
finally there's this ability to also
look at proteins and this is early data
just from
[Music]
some of our initial protein analysis
and as a cancer researcher and
oncologist
there are a couple things that stood out
to me one of them was that pdl1
ctla4 ido1 and sting were all
somewhat enriched in our high viral
cases
indicating that even though we have a
robust interferon response with
macrophages
there are some immune checkpoints and
other immune regulatory proteins that
are there that may be suppressing t cell
response this is obviously early data
but this also demonstrates the ability
of this platform to uh
see intrapulmonary heterogeneity so
overall in terms of the summary of our
work
you really see a temporal correlation of
duration of illness and viral rna in the
lungs this is consistent with
some of my colleagues on this uh webinar
as well
the spectrum of interference response
and high versus low patients
is is quite clear and the intra-patient
and inter patient heterogeneity that can
be seen
with uh the uh nanostring geomets
platform
can really show us differences in immune
response to the virus
obviously this has implications for the
timing and patient selection for
antivirals and our immune modulating
therapies as we think about trials
that are ongoing in in future trials and
i hope that we can identify
protein rna markers with my colleagues
in infectious disease in
in basic science and clinical um
microbiology to sort of identify ways of
providing new therapeutic interventions
for these patients
as i say you know these things uh often
take a village but
in this case this took a metropolis we
had uh
great collaborators internally at the
mgh as well as at columbia academically
nanastring the broad institute acd
and without all of these people working
together there was no way we would be
able to accomplish this so quickly
thank you very much
thank you so much david that was
wonderful uh our next
presenter will be uh dr asa
cycle storm she will be speaking about
the spatial insights
of lung pathology in covet 19 autopsies
thank you sarah for tonight's
introduction yes
i am very happy to be invited to this
conference and to speak here
um so we have been very fortunate at the
broad institute
to be able to team up with three larger
boss and area hospitals
and together we have been able to run
multiple kobe 19
related research projects but for this
presentation
i would like to focus on the autopsy
organ cohort that we have
both from covenanting patients as well
as healthy references and
from these tissues we have run single
cell single nuclei rna-seq
and also spatial analysis with the nano
strain platform
this table here shows the 17 autopsy
atlas
study donors that we have included in
this study
and you can also see the number of
different
tissue types that we have from each
individual
we also have a wide variety of ages from
30 to up to 90 years old
people and they have had multiple
different organ failures
and they have been intubated for certain
amounts
of days and we have some pmi times there
as well for the
single cell studies
and the autopsy profiling objectives
have been mainly three
so we the first one is to atlas the
diseased tissues
in detail on single cell level and then
we would like to compare the disease
versus healthy tissue
and look for the changes in cell
composition
and third we want to also study the
infected cell types and what
induced gene expression programs there
are and what
cell cell interactions are changed upon
viral infection
um so the spatial arm of this cohort
uh was done on ffpa material from larger
tissue sections
and from these 17 autopsies four of them
were assayed with the nanostring geomics
dsp platform
as well as the rna scope assay
and in total we have nine cova 19
deceased
subjects and three controlled
non-infected lungs
and um start of the project
we focused on the lung and especially
the left upper lung lobe
of the distal part of the lung and this
was
basically because we had a lot of single
nuclei single cell
sequencing already done on this region
and in the table here you see the nine
covid
patients and their different ages organ
failures and also
the lengths of the seeds they've had so
it's very variable there
and we got all these samples from
brigham and women's hospital
and where they have done an initial
immunohistochemistry of the viral
levels of these patients and they found
that three were negative
on immunohistochemistry three had low
positive levels of virus whereas
two were moderately positive and one
very highly positive
and we have been using three different
assays from the nanostring geomics
platform to assay these samples
both and we use the cancer
transcriptomic atlas
the cta and also added in the copic
spiking probes
we have also used the whole
transcriptome atlas
which is eighteen hundred or eighteen
thousand transcripts
so covering all different pathways as
well as using the covalent spiking
probes
and third we use the protein assay for
immuno oncology
a 78 amino antibody
protein assay and also added in the
covid protein modules with a
spike protein and tempras h2 cathepsin
and an rna helicase called ddx5
and our goal was to try and assay our
wise
or to match our eyes over different
these different assays
on consecutive sides
um we started by initially screening
these samples with the rna scope probe
towards the source code we do genome
and we also used then for morphology
staining we used
the epithelium morphology marketplan
cytokeratin
and also cd45 staining and we did rna
roi placement with the help of a
pathologist
doing this online with us live
and the roi bay areas we selected was
based on the signal we had on the
sarskovid
from the rna scope slides
and we also had the pathological
assessment and annotation while we were
placing the rois and we mainly have
focused on alveoli
but also we have taken airways blood
vessels glands etc
and we have sampled around 200 regions
of interest
across all samples per assay
and the roi were segmented most of them
with
the pansy k so we have around 200 pound
ck
negative regions and 170 pounds decay
positive segments
sequenced per essay
next i'm going to show you some slides
of example of
patients so some of these were negative
on immunohistochemistry for the virus
and we also see that
to the right here you see the rna and
scope slides
we also see no signal for the virus in
these samples
and over to the left you see the pancake
cd45 staining and the roi placement we
took there
so we have eight alveoli two airway and
four blood vessels collected for
this particular sample
here is another example of a patient
with moderate
positive immunohistochemistry level for
the virus and with rna scope you can
also see that we have
very regional differences as many of the
previous speaker have
already mentioned we have regional
differences of viral
load in the line lobes and this enables
the roi
placement to we can capture areas of
both high and low covered
rates um yes
this third sample here is the
the sample which were highly positive
for the virus
and it's a 68 year old with
copd which had lung and heart failure
and we were able to collect rois from
both the
rna scope slide as well as the pancake
cd45 stain slide
so we have 23 ris in total collected for
both of these slides and we tried to
match the rois as closely as we could
and here you can also see the regional
differences in
viral signal on the rna scope slide
here are some roi zoom ins of different
regions and you can see up in green on
the top
we have the pencil k signal which is
very positive for the virus shown in red
to the right
and here you also see the segmentation
profile segmentation masks that we used
for these samples
to collect and to the right
on the lower panel you can see also the
cd45 signal that we have tried to ramp
up here
we have not really been able to use this
antibody
uh it's been hard to
to segment on and yeah we we don't have
really specific staining of the cd45
unfortunately
so we have mostly done pan ck
segmentation on our
otherwise
um another thing that was interesting so
we could group
our rois into regions of either
very low co with expression medium and
high
and this down in the histogram here you
can see
also the nanostring probes for the
spike proteins and the orf 1ab
viral genome and we can to the
left you see all the pan ck negative
segments
and they have been ordered from negative
medium to high
and covered concentrations for the rna
scope slide and you can also appreciate
that for the pancake positive
segments we see an increase in viral
reads over the when we go from negative
to medium to high
so it has a nice correlation both
nanostring data with the rna scope data
and we have also run of course
differential expression
and first of all we wanted to study what
is the difference between the pancake
positive
epithelial cells and the non-epithelial
segmented rois
and to the right in this volcano plot
you see the log fall change
of the pan-ck positive segments and
where we can see a lot of of course
epithelial cell markers
being enriched as well as surfactant
proteins for the pneumocytes
but we also see a lot of
pro-inflammatory cytokines and
chemokines as well as the spike protein
is
significantly enriched in these segments
of panzy k
and we have also run differential
expression between the code with high
versus code with low regions so in
yellow you see
circled the low coverage regions of them
and this is shown for the rna scope
sample so we have a
run differential expression expression
between the six code with low versus 14
copied high
roi so non-segmented this time
and again or we we see a high
enrichment of the viral reads in the
covet high
regions as compared to the code with low
and
in addition we have a lot of
interference stimulated genes
in the cobit high areas as well
we have done the same differential
expression but here just looking into
the pan ck
positive segments and again we see the
the enrichment of the viral transcript
in the covet high
regions as well as pro-inflammatory
cytokines and chemokines
um interestingly when we when we um
look into the differential expression
between the covet high and co
with low regions in the pan ck negative
segments everything that is
non-epithelial cells
we don't see many genes that are
significantly different so meaning that
we do have a really focal and
yeah the virus is really affecting
locally and as i told you we have
12 samples in total and
this are our three control line
parenchyma samples that we have used
we are right now trying to to analyze
all the data from these samples
so we are trying to do it for both cta
and vta but unfortunately i cannot
i don't have the results yet for the
whole cohort
but we're taking around 40 rois from the
control
control groups
for both the cta and vta and
this slide here shows all the nine
copied patients
that has been included in all the roi
placements
so we have around 150 rois
a majority segmented on panzik a
positive and negative
for both the ct and vta assay and we are
planning to take the same for the
protein assay
but we have done that already and we
will
analyze it on the encounter system and
we have a wide variety of
selection of alveoli bronchial airway
and vessels
that we will dig deeper into
i just wanted to end by showing you some
data from the single cell single nuclei
rna-seq cohort from the 17 samples from
the same line region
and the different cell types that we
collect
for these 17 samples and
what you can also see to the right are
the viral enrichment of viral counts
that we have for the different cell
types so interestingly we find a lot of
viral raids but overall it's not a lot
of viral reads in the single cell data
but the
reads we find they end up in the
macrophages
whether this is due to engulfment of
apoptotic virally infected cells or
whether they're getting infected
it's something we are looking into
and also in the single cell single
nuclear data we also
find that there is a high variability
between
patients when it comes to the viral load
that we have
so future direction we are gonna of
course analyze the full data set
of the 12 donors across the around 200
collected rois that we have
for the different segments and correlate
gene and protein expression in matched
rois
and run differential expression in
clinically annotated regions
and then we're planning to use the
single cell single nuclei data
to do data deconvolution from matched
samples
and also run cell compositions per roi
with the help of that and then finally
do some cluster analysis of the rys
and yes then i just want to
end by this an acknowledgement slide
it's a huge
coher or a lot of people involved in
these studies
i want to highlight just aviva norit for
leading this project
and sami dominic and malik has been
instrumental for the spatial arm to make
it work
beau and jaming and joshua has been
working on the data analysis
and isaac solomon has been the person
giving us the samples from brigham and
women jonathan chen and avinash wagre
are the pathologists that have helped us
with the roa
roi selection and also i want to
highlight a lot of
very good collaborative people at
nanostring that has helped us a lot
errol marty bryan and also you sarah
so thank you everyone
thank you so much it was a wonderful
presentation
and our next speaker will be gordon jang
from beth israel deaconess he's going to
be speaking about
the transcriptomics of sars kobe 2
induced lung injury
and telling us about his special
transcriptomics approach
thank you sarah it's a really a
privilege to be invited to this uh
panel of experts on copyrighting
research and so the title of my talk is
the transcriptomics of
south korea to induce the learning jury
a spatial transcriptomics approach
and this is my disclosure and the
disclosure i'm not putting into
this project um so the closure is that
i am not a pulmonologist i have never
studied viral biology
i'm a hepatologist um so i think
if anything you can learn from my story
is that
this technology how this technology can
enable an investigator to tap into a
new field with uh with
a lot of barriers being overcome
in the situation so sas kobe 2 you know
has impacted
us everybody across the world
dramatically
um i have been following south korea ii
early on
in early january the reason because my
wife is actually from wuhan
and i've been seeing the pandemic
unfolding in
china and i've been following that and
in march
we start to see cases uh accumulating uh
in new york and
then in massachusetts as well uh in
mid-march
we were told that our lab needs to be
closed and
um earlier this year we've been
collaborating with nanostring and we've
been thinking about
ways to cooperate on projects regarding
with the fatty liver disease
um but then um i have to tell them that
we cannot do that anymore
um so uh then idea came up that whether
we can use our
our resources to work on project that's
uh
south korea two related and uh and here
we are
and i just wanna show the timeline this
is how the case is increased
in march and april very rapidly and
april the 20th was our first joint
meeting that we
we started this project officially
so this is basically uh supported by a
hospital
in the um in in in really a teamwork
so this is the design of our single
center study
um so we we're going to collect the
tissues from patients unfortunately
succumb to the kova 19 virus
and we really emphasized on getting the
tissue fresh
so we had a interventional radiologist
on call
and will come in to do ultrasound guided
and needle biopsy at different organs
within three hours of death so this
really allowed us to minimize the code
ischemia time
once we have the tissue we'll do
multiple passes of the 16-gauge biopsy
somebody should be um fixed
and will be used for spatial
transcriptomics analysis using the wta
platform um some of tissues are rapidly
flash frozen in liquid nitrogen and
these tissues will then be processed
for single nuclear sequencing and then
we're going to
combine the analysis and try to try to
gain more in-depth information about
how the virus impacted the
host response and the journalists from
our team
talked more about the uh single nuclear
sequencing analysis and i'm going to
focus on
just the spatial transcriptomics in the
learn that we saw
so this is a h and e staining of one of
the biopsy samples
um from a patient and this actually are
two pieces
uh um two two sections of the same
biopsy
stained by h and e so one feature about
uh
kobe 19 is that it's really
patchy um the clinical features are
imaging of coming 19 if you remember
that this is a patchy ground glass
opacity seen at least
in the early phase in the periphery of
the lung
this is actually quite unique in terms
of
the infectious etiologies of the lung
and if you remember at some point that
in juan they used the imaging criterias
to make the diagnosis when the
diagnostic kits were not
available in large quantities um so
this shows that even on the single
biopsy you actually can capture
regions that has very different degree
of uh
disease in the left you have relatively
normal tissue that has a very thin
single cell layer of the alveoli
epithelial layer
and on the right you have a lot of
infiltration of inflammatory cells and
edemas and maybe fibrosis as well
so the next thing we can do is to stain
the tissue with a
susceptibility to antibody in this
example and this is obviously
not very satisfactory because uh
it's not very quantitative and you
always have concern how specific
is the antibody and antibody um
in this case we're dealing with a viral
protein that
can either be intracellular or
extracellular
the other technology that has been quite
immature for some time is adding sexual
hybridization that our lab
also use a lot in the past for labor
research
so this technology basically relies on a
rna probe
that is linked to some chemical
amplifier that allows you to see that
either underlying microscopy or you can
use fluorescent labels and you can you
can see that in the frost and microscopy
so this significantly close to the gap
for research when when when the subject
is new and the antibody has not been
validated well
so when we apply the rna scope in this
case
um to the biopsy sample this is the same
tissue that you saw previously
um here uh the cytoscopy ii viral spike
gene was uh
shown in red and h2 is in yellow and
tempos is
showing green and the dna is in blue
you can see the two regions relatively
normal region
as well as the inflamed region on the
same
sample if you
zoom in you can see that this layer of
highly packed cells likely is the
bronchial epithelium has
a lot of viral signal whereas
right behind that in the in the in the
methane chemical region there's a
significantly less the variable density
is significantly less
um on the left if you look at the
relatively normal region
um you can also see some viral signals
the viral signals
sometimes cluster in regions where you
see a
infiltration of cells with a very scant
cytoplasm probably indicating these
immune cells so nanostring
geomax is really a technology that is
very similar to on a scope that
overcomes the barrier of antibody that
you can use
a rna probe but unlike any scope that
you can only look at two or three genes
at a time
you can look at an entire human genome
so here
we use the wta platform which covers
over 18 000 genes so basically the
probes are connected with a uv cleavable
key instead of using a a signal that
will amplify
um to to generate the light here
you just count the number of keys to get
the quantitative information of the copy
of each
gene transcript so this technology
can be applied to biopsy tissues so
these are
tissue biopsy as you can see the
relative size of each our eye that we
select
is a little bit different from the
previous talks that you saw
from the tissue block from tissue
resection
so in this biopsy these two two
needle biopsies actually from the same
patient you can see that it actually
covers a wide variety of
of a phenotype there are regions that
the alveoli looks relatively normal
whereas there are regions every online
looks very inflamed very busy with
infiltrative
immune cells you have the bronchial
epithelium and you have regions with ibo
light that relatively looks normal but
seems to have edema
in the air space
so the spatial transcriptomics allows us
to basically see how these uh
regions cluster so so we we analyzed a
total of uh
91 hour eyes and one out of these 91
hour eyes does not meet
the minimum number of new um cell counts
to be to be successfully
analyzed and uh we have a total of
uh 18 375 genes
and we were able to have a reliable
data on 85 of the genes so this is a
very
broad coverage of the transcriptome and
you can
immediately see that these different ios
are clustering
um on the left you have the pca plot
and on the right you have the sne plot
and you can see
that the distinct cluster is the
epithelial
cluster whereas the avionic cluster is
inflamed versus normal
relatively unknown continuum the other
thing we noticed
is that there's quite a bit of
variability
on the transcriptal analysis based on
the individuals
individuals do cluster but even within
the individual the normal
versus uh inflamed ideologies
still separate based on their
phenotype
so this is a one analysis of comparing
the transcriptome of a bronchial
epithelium
versus a normal ibra so this is sort of
served as an internal control to see
whether we can actually pick up
differences
using this uh analysis and we can see
that uh
on the left is the volcano plot and
there's
quite a bit of a variance across these
two type of allies
and on the right top you have the top
gene that is
related with enriched in
bronchial epithelium this is the this is
the pathway involved
in the all glycan synthesis which makes
total sense this is what the
bronchial epithelium usually do whereas
in the normal ibr light the highest
ranking pathway is the
lt3 that is the pathway involved in
immune regulation
which indicating that in the normal
alveoli you have
more immune cells
so this is the analysis that is more
telling of the
pathology this is we are comparing the
inflamed region in front of your life
versus normal appearing alveoli
and it and it's it's quite surprising
that you can you can actually see quite
a bit of a variance across these two
type of our eyes and
the genes that stands out the top
ranking pathway
is again the interferon gamma signaling
pathway which is the
same theme that has been discussed
previously
seems to be replicated here that it not
not only between
high viral counter versus low viral kind
but here in the same subject
subject between the relatively normal
appearing versus
inflamed regions the the most prominent
pathway is the interferon gamma pathway
well as in the normal ivo light the most
prominent pathway is the surfactant
producing pathway
which is what normal evolutionary would
do indicating that in flame the
situations
these functions are lost
so this is the analysis comparing um the
our eyes based on the viral count
so we group the barrier count into three
groups um
low value account medium variable count
and high value count
score zero one and a two so here you
have a two by two plot
on the left you have the normal ibo line
uh and on the right
you have the inflamed rbo light and on
the top row you have score one compared
to score zero
and on the bottom row you have the score
two narrow counts compared to square
zero
so one message we can learn from this is
that in the inflamed regions
the amount of viral count does not seem
to make a huge difference which makes
biological sense because
once the tissue is inflamed what you're
seeing is basically
overwhelmed by the inflammatory response
but in the relatively normal
regions comparing regions with a
moderate viral account to higher account
there's quite a bit of a
difference so on the right of the genes
that is different
is a 5 lipo oxygenase this is the gene
involved in the
modification of a fatty acid to
prostaglycan
and this is a password involved in
information
finally this technology also allows us
to do cell deconvolution as
looted by other speakers so here is an
example of
using a established single cell
reference profile to do deconvolution
and we can see that the clusters
demonstrated a different
cell composition
on the left is the clustering using the
tsne method and on the right you can see
the deconvolution
and this plot shows the different
composition
uh in the pie chart and the bigger the
region indicates
the higher amount of the
cells present in that roi you can
clearly see the cluster
that has a lot of orange that is the
bronchial epithelium cluster
that has a a lot of the epithelial cells
as well as acidity cells
whereas in the inflamed regions you can
see the blue the size of the blue is
increasing that is the macrophage again
this goes back to the theme that the
inflammation
in copper 19 patients is associated with
a increase of the lack of ages
so of course a lot of analysis are still
ongoing and hopefully
we'll be able to give you more findings
from
this type of analysis so with that i
would like to conclude
my talk and i thank um the teams
involved in this
effort of course this is a effort that
cannot be done
without a huge team uh to support this
and on the left are the teams involved
at the passage of deaconess medical
center
jones is involved in a lot of single
cell analysis
and jonathan hatch is our pathologist
has been guided us
in the our ice election um i want to
specifically thank ogre who has been
collecting the tissues she's a
radiologist has been getting tissues
with
a very short window to allow the study
to be done using
very fresh samples on the right we have
collaborators from from our nanostream
colleagues
talent and jason are the main
contributor for the analysis to this
point
and lulu and again are involving our
selection
eric sarah instrumental to allow this
project to happen
thank you very much thank you so much to
all of our speakers for joining
us today and sharing their wonderful
data it was it was really exciting to
see how
we're all taking different profiling
strategies to understand and elucidate
the biology behind the covid19 infection
i have just a few questions for our
panel discussion and i'm going to ask
each of our
our speakers to answer a few particular
questions
we're going to start off with rob
schwartz and robin
interested to hear how the challenges
around sample access have guided
the research strategy that you've chosen
to take with these copic 19 tissues
well sarah i thank you again for the
opportunity to
participate in this uh seminar as well
as for the opportunity to collaborate
with
nana string and giving alan and i
this uh wonderful access to this
technology now
to answer your question um you know
obviously uh sample access is you know
has and
remains to be a major challenge uh here
um and i think across the united states
now with that said i mean we have
amassed
an autopsy a large autopsy series
and i think you know one of the
challenges i think is the overall
variability
that's present within the the tissues
themselves
and what i mean by that is that some of
the patients died very early on
in their disease course um after having
been infected and so those patients
uh as we've learned over time have very
high viral loads as compared to patients
who died later
in their disease course and so that's
not something that we knew initially
when we were
selecting uh samples for uh tissue
analysis
and for um you know for the
uh geomets spatial analysis and i think
that's
um you know you know initially uh
created some uh
challenge um in the analysis of these
tissues now we've been able to go back
and add back kind of those tissues that
we know now
or you know are very rich in stars kovi
ii viral transcripts and are more
representative
of this earlier cohort of disease
thank you rob um and i wanted to direct
the same question to gordon because i
know that he
you know he mentioned in his
presentation as well some of the
challenges and strategies that the beth
israel team had put in place
yeah thank you sarah to have the
opportunity to um to
to join this uh exciting uh foreign and
always the exciting uh
investigators um so uh so back to your
question about
the sample access i think this is a
learning process
we sort of learned about the challenge
in this particular project and they
learned about the
advantage of this platform for the kobe
project initially you know nobody knows
about
how to how to how to do the safety
controls and
there's a little bit of challenge how to
do that safely so we we sort of go
around the uh uh biopsy approach rather
than getting the actual organ
which require a tissue dissection um
so what we learned from this study is
that this technology actually works
pretty well on biopsy samples
this actually is a very interesting
thing that
because the clinical biopsy is the most
common way that a clinicians get tissue
and if a technology is compatible with
biopsy samples this will greatly open up
opportunities for for research on
existing samples
samples that has been banked in clinical
studies
in a situation like that um obviously
you know
the cutting edge transcriptomics
techniques
has allowed us to really learn a lot but
a lot of these techniques
require samples that are fresh and then
once you fix that it
makes things much harder and this
technology
um allows you to work on samples that
has been fixed
and that is widely available on
formatting fixed
perfect combative tissue which i think
is a huge advantage
thank you so much gordon i'm going to
turn my next question to
assa and also i was really interested to
hear about your experiences with
doing roi selection because you have
access to an instrument at your own site
can you speak a little bit about what
that process was like for you
sure all right so
yeah it's been a very interesting
process and we have been
multiple people involved in the roi
selection and what we've done is that we
have pretty much
one great feature about the dsp machine
is that you can remotely access it
from various locations so we have had
two pathologists
logging onto the machine and then on
over zoom
we have discussed like individual slides
over multiple different zoom
events and yeah during the afternoon
where we placed the rois and it's been
an ongoing
like very lively discussion about where
to put them
and what areas to sample and so on
so and that is really what takes time
with a dsp machine
definitely and also to get the
segmentation
adjustments to correctly give you the
the best areas as well
perfect thank you it sounds like a very
engaging process
it is uh and then one one question then
to
alan please once um once we've done the
visualizations
once we've collected the data what have
you learned about
data visualization throughout um
throughout these experiments what's
worked well what do we still need to do
uh in general to to help bring these
images and these molecular data
to life and make them uh as
interpretable as possible
well i i find that the um the
visualizations especially by cell type
and expression by cell type is immensely
valuable especially as it's
geographically related to the section
because we
as the pathologists have seen the
section we've seen the individual cells
we've imagined what they are but when we
see them
confirmed in this way and then we can
get expression at even
within the different areas of the tissue
it's extremely valuable
visualization i i found i think the
biggest challenge that we
encountered is just the heterogeneity of
the samples themselves and
and being able to establish a proper
baseline that remains a challenge
truly normal tissue is is hard to come
by perfect thanks so much and i i agree
with you it's it's
it's uh great to see the underlying
biology really coming through in the
data but it does present some
uh some challenges to overcome in terms
of how we think about interpreting it um
so we're out of time today another round
of thanks to all of our speakers they
were fantastic presentations
uh thank you to our audience too for
joining and listening i hope that you
have enjoyed this
special biology conferences wonderful to
be spend this time with you today